are supplements to support the mitochondria.
Best questions to support the mitochondria.
Best supplements to support the mitochondria.
Again, if a person has mitochondrial issues,
so what is the mitochondria?
The mitochondria is really responsible for making energy for the body.
So that in the mitochondria, you create ATP.
So ATP is energy that is needed for that cell,
that is needed for the body.
So if the mitochondria has dysfunction,
and there's a lot of books out there that talk about different diseases,
our mitochondrial diseases.
Cancer is a metabolic disease.
It talks about dysfunction in the mitochondria.
So chronic fatigue, you know, people point to,
well, it's the mitochondria, you're not making that energy.
But even with that, you've got to figure out why.
So before we start just throwing supplements,
this is going to help mitochondrial function.
So we're going to support it with this supplement.
You have to find out why you have,
if you truly do have mitochondrial dysfunction,
and then why you have mitochondrial dysfunction,
it's all that.
There's many reasons why a person can have mitochondrial dysfunction,
and one can be toxins, one, you know, heavy metals,
all sorts of things that could interrupt mitochondrial ability to make energy.
But it's much bigger than that.
A person can have energy issues that are tied to mitochondrial function at all.
They're tied to adenia.
They have energy issues that are tied to chronic inflammation.
You have to have energy issues that are tied to hypothyroidism.
You could have energy issues that are tied to a lot of different things.
So it's a good digging to the reason why.
And I don't want to disappoint everybody,
but I'm not going to be a doctor that's just going to say,
just take this or this symptom because you're not finding out why.
So you've got to dig to that.
And there are some labs that you could do to figure that out.
I got to have this on the holistic health out,
or about digging to the reason why,
because it is so important to really achieve ultimate success
at anything you're doing.
If you go look at our website, cuttersclinic.com,
you could go up an upper tab where it says courses.
Our best course to take for these overall health issues
is the chronic disease and autoimmune course,
where I go into great depth through that course
on why you should run certain labs,
why you should do certain tests to figure out
and what you would find on that test,
and what you would look for on that test,
how you would best interpret that test
to find out the reasons why I have an issue.
So that chronic disease and autoimmune course
is going to be your best thing to do to look at that.
Even if you're working with a functional medicine doctor now,
maybe he or she doesn't have as much time clinically to explain the result.
Maybe you're running some of these labs.
Maybe they don't have the time to explain these labs in great detail to you.
Well, I created videos on that course.
So I did it so that my patients I could just say,
go to module two of the chronic disease course.
I know you're on that.
Watch some of the labs on blah, blah, blah.
Or watch some of the videos on this subject
because that saves me time.
If you would not be charged for my time to explain this to you
when you could go watch a 12 minute video and explain it to you,
then you can watch it two times if you need to.
So that's the thing to do.